who said it draft edition I'm gonna read
the quote we're gonna see if big cat can
figure out who said it first one we
don't know life's too short you don't
know how this is going to work its
people drafting defensive tackles when
they already have two stud starters why
are you doing that
it's where the value meets the draft
pick who said it big cat
so I swore to you before I did not look
these up I obviously just by doing my
own job I know a couple of these and
this one was the easiest one on the
board because it is clearly Dave
gentlemen whenever he starts with though
we don't know life's too short
come on Dave gentlemen it's insane to
draft someone and go into your press
come and say we don't know life's too
short like that's that's crazy just take
that out of the NFL the draft when
you're making a huge franchise decision
if you're working in a corporation you
make a big business decision and your
first response is we don't know life's
too short I'm disappointed you didn't
say I know for a fact that it's Dave
gentlemen but you did get the correct
answer you are one for one next up there
were flashier players players that other
teams may have had higher on their
boards we knew he'd probably be there
everybody else had all the big names up
there but he was our guy he checked all
the boxes who's that it okay so this is
either Jon Gruden or mike Mayock because
it has to be the cleveland farrell pick
that was the pick that everyone was
shocked by that said he could be a
twenty year old around the 20 range in
the first round they took him with the
fourth overall pick so I don't know if
it was Jon Gruden or Mike Matt there you
go mike Mayock you there yeah you got
Mike Mac and it had to be mocked because
Gruden's never gonna say it because he's
not responsible for anything it's always
somebody else's decision true let
somebody else go out and defend the
decision so yes Mike Mac was the one who
defended the decision all right next up
we picked the player we wanted to pick
I'm almost positive dave has no clue
what our draft board would be I don't
know which draft board he knows but he
does not know ours who's that it okay so
this has
be someone from the Redskins because
they're talking about someone who picked
a quarterback in Dave gentlemen and the
Redskins somehow got luck lucked out
because I really do think they would
have traded up for Dwayne Haskins but it
fell right into their lap so probably
Bruce Allen but maybe Jay Gruden you got
to pick one Bruce Allen there we go yeah
that one yeah you got a little you got a
little tip there all right
a couple more before we wrap he's known
as a tough-ass competitor just watch him
play I've seen him play against Michigan
a few times and he looked pretty good I
hated him then now I love him
okay is this John Lynch I don't know I
will try to figure out the Michigan
angle here like is he talking about Nick
Bosa I'm gonna say John Lynch but I feel
like this is the one I'm least confident
in and no you are incorrect I have the
key here I don't even know who it was I
have to look it up John Harbaugh on
trace McSorely trace McSorely the Penn
State quarterback who will be a jack of
all trades in Baltimore Eric decosta the
GM of the Ravens told me earlier this
week offense special teams and defense
for trace McCoy at McSorely in Baltimore
all right one more before we run out of
time I'm just going to be upfront and
honest about the elephant in the room we
already talked to our team about it
we're good use it talk about it it's a
healthy thing so we feel good about it
and we're going to get this thing right
who's that it I'm passing on this
because I know who said it and you're
doing this to just needle me and guess
what Mike we've talked about it it's a
healthy thing so we feel good about it
we're going to get this thing right okay
we're gonna move on we've totally done
kickers this weekend at the Chicago
Bears rookie mini coach Matt Negi said
eight kickers is one of the folks at PFT
pointed out they're all not arriving in
the same car but yes eight kickers I
think it's 11 total special team I think
there's some punters maybe two it's
insane like it's insane that we're going
eight kickers I whatever we talked about
it Mike you can't live in the past you
can't sit here and live in the past
talk about double doinks you can't
hurt me anymore we're closer to the
season than we were to the double doink
I don't know my math on that but it
feels like that's correct so I'm ready
for 2019 at some point like don't you
just see if there's guys currently on
the team that play other positions that
maybe can kick aren't you better off
that way
like maybe true Biscay can kick right
let's go the old Lou Groza George Blanda
route and have somebody double up I
wouldn't be shocked if if Khalil Mac or
Tariq Cohen both just phenomenal
phenomenal athletes could kick a
football farther than Kody parky I just
don't know and I like the idea of
bringing in that many guys and basically
having a gong show because if you can
win that reality show competition if you
can step up and make the kicks when all
these other guys are trying to make the
kicks then maybe you'll be able to make
a kick during a game I think it's a
fairly simple piece of logic yeah
the piece of something smart things it's
it's a new day the Bears are doing smart
things
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports